ميدانيا افادت مواقع اوكرانيه محليه بسماع
دوي انفجارات فجر اليوم في شبه جزيره
القرم وقال حاكم انه تم اسقاطه طائرتين
مسيرتين اوكراني فوق البحر مضيفا ان تلك
الاصوات ناجمه عن عمل المضادات الجوي
وقالت السلطات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه خرسون
وزباروجيا وميكو لايف جنوبيه بلادنا القصف
الروسيه على مدنها وبلداتها تجدد فجر
اليوم وقالت الاداره العسكريه في زاباروجي
ان القصف الروسيه خلف دمار في المباني
واستهدف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه كما افادت
السلطات المحليه في ميكو لايف بان القصف
سادف المناطق الساحليه في المقاطعه ويبقى
سلطات المحليه في خرسون فقط قصفت اوصفت
المقاطعه بالمدفعيه وقذائف الهاون
للمزيد حول الاوضاع الميدانيه ينضم الينا
منكير مراسل الجزيره تامر الصومال اهلا بك
تامر وضعنا في اخر المستجدات الميدانيه
المستجدات السياسيا وميدانيا سياسيا هنا
في كيف ميدانيا في عديد المقاطعات
الجنوبيه والعسكريه وانا انتظر هذا الهواء
كانت هنالك تصريحات في الحقيقه لافته
لمستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الذي قال بان
القوات القياده الروسيه ستعمل على
الاستفاده خلال الايام المقبله من همم
قوات الاحتياطيه وتحدث عن اكثر من 200,000
من المقاتلين الروس وقال بان ذلك سوف يصعب
همم علينا همم في الجبهات التي سوف يستخدم
فيها ذلك الاحتياط لكنه تعهد نقلا عن
القوات الاوكرانيه بانه همم بانه سوف يتم
العمل على استنزاف تلك القوات في غضون
شهرين الى ثلاثه اشهر وتحدثت جدد في
الحقيقه مستشار رئيس الاوكراني همم الحديث
عن همم التعبئه العسكريه التي تقوم بها
القوات في هذه الاثناء وقال بان الشهر هذا
الشهر الجديد من العام الجديد سوف يكون
هنالك حراكا متواصله من قبل روسيا لتعبئه
مزيد من
القوات الروسيه وهذا الحديث في الحقيقه
اشار اليه ايضا الرئيس الاوكراني يوم امس
عندما قال بان قاده روسيا سوف يعملون على
القاء كل ما لديهم من اجل تغيير دفه الحرب
من اجل تاخير الهزيمه على حد وصفه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الحديث عن الهزيمه بات
امرا متكرر بالنسبه للقاده السياسيين
وكبار القاده السياسيين ايضا والعسكريين
هنا في كياف هزيمه القوات الروسيه ايضا
يقول مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني وانا انقل
عن خلال الدقائق الاخيره وهو يتحدث يقول
بان همم اوكرانيا حصلت على مساعدات عسكريه
كثيره خلال العام الماضي وان هذه
المساعدات سوف تتواصل وان اوكرانيا لن
تتنازل عن كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه وانها
سوف تواصل القتال الى ابعد احد وابعد مدى
هذه التصريحات جاءت بعد ساعات من تصريحات
مماثله للمستشار في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل موديلات الذي قال بان كل من يريد
ان يحدثنا عن المفاوضات مع الجانب الروسي
عليه ان يتذكر جيدا بان روسيا تقتل الشعب
الاوكراني وتحتل اجزاء من الارض
الاوكرانيه وان المبادئ واضحه لا تتجزا
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وهي انسحاب كامل القوات
الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما فيها
شبه جزيره الكرمه الاتصالات ايضا السياسيه
الدبلوماسيه ضلت متواصله وقام بها في
الحقيقه عدد كبير منها الرئيس الاوكرانيا
يوم امس في همم مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
وعدد من القادها الاوروبيين حتى هم على
مواصله ارسال الدعم العسكري وقال بان هذا
العام سوف يكون عاما حاسما بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه على طول الجبهات الجنوبيه
والشرقيه كان هنالك ايضا اتصال همم اجراه
قائد الجيش الاوكراني رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه في يوم امس حتى هو ايضا على
ارسال مزيد من المساعدات الاسراء في ارسال
تلك المساعدات وقال بان انتصار اوكرانيا
في هذه الحرب على روسيا هو انتصار لكامل
اوروبا ومن شاني ان يحقق الامن في اوروبا
تحدث ايضا عن تطورات الميدانيه في الجبهات
قال بان
القوات الاوكرانيه تمسك بزمام الامور بشكل
تدريجي في مقاطعه زبروجه جنوبيه البلاد لا
سيما في ظل القصف الاوكراني المتواصل على
مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه بالمناسبه كانت تحدثت صباح هذا
اليوم عن مقتل وجرح نحو 260 من القوات
الروسيه في ترك ماكمل في زاباروجا وتحدثت
ايضا عن تدمير عدد كبير من المعدات قائد
الجيش الاوكراني ايضا تحدث عن محاولات
اوكرانيه متواصله لحمايه الاجواء
وقال بان القصف الروسي يتواصل على خيرسون
ونحن نعمل بكل ما يمكننا من اجل حمايه
المد وحمايه البنيه التحتيه القصف تواصل
اليوم بشكل مكثف على خير سون وزبروديا
وبالاضافه الى المناطق الساحليه في
ميكولايت تتحدث الادارات العسكريه هنالك
عن ان القصف يتواصل بشكل اساسي على البنيه
التحتيه ايضا كان لافتنا اشار اليه قائد
الجيش الاوكراني خلال اتصاله بنظيره
الامريكي عندما قال بان القوات الاوكرانيه
تحافظ وتمسك ايضا بزمان المبادره على
الحدود مع بلاروسيا وقال بان الاوضاع او
حتى اللحظه هناك امنه وان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقوم بادوارها الدفاعيه همم في
الحقيقه تطورات على الصعيد على الاخر فيما
يتعلق بالقصف والقصف المتبادل تحديدا
بالمدفعيه الثقيله متواصل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه تحديدا عند ضفتين
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه الاضاءات تامر
معنا كيف